this is a production of Cornell
University
and so as Bob said what I'd like to do
to talk to you today is recent work that
we've been doing essentially testing the
hypothesis that plants have over
invested in chlorophyll and so I will
get into that both from the standpoint
of theory and experiment and it's an
ongoing project and so we don't
necessarily have an answer but I'll tell
you about why we're interested in doing
it before doing that I guess I'd like to
step back and just try to put this kind
of research into a more global context
context really the challenges that
agriculture is going to be facing over
the next three or four decades the place
I wanted to start is here many of you
will recognize this as a textbook figure
of the global carbon cycle in fact it's
only half the global carbon cycle it has
to do with a terrestrial global carbon
cycle and I and I picked that out
particularly because of course that's
where most of our food comes from the
terrestrial side and what it shows is
that this process of photosynthesis
removes amount of carbon from the
atmosphere that's equivalent to 15
percent of all the co2 in the atmosphere
you know in co2 in the atmosphere is
about 400 parts per million and there's
about 800 Giga tons of carbon in the
atmosphere and so we've had 120 Giga
tons that are taken out about 60 are are
essentially very quickly returned to the
atmosphere by autotrophic respiration of
plants so this is the amount of
photosynthate the plants used grow and
to maintain themselves and what's left
is approximately another 60 Giga tons
and for all practical purposes it
supports everything else on the planet
and so it supports microbial life and it
supports all kinds of animal life of
course part of that is us feeding
ourselves and feeding our livestock so
the difference between this gross
photosynthesis and the net
photosynthesis is often called net
primary productivity and so the net
primary productivity of the terrestrial
biome is estimated I have here at 60 but
it's actually estimated at about 50
six Giga tons of carbon per year so I
think it's informative to think about
you know what are those those biomes
individual biomes across the world that
support that net primary productivity
and you're probably not surprised to
find out that the tropical rainforests
account for about a third of it
the vast manners that are deployed
around the world account for about a
third of it but what may surprise you is
that already the cultivation of the
crops that we use to eat and feed our
livestock account for about 15% of the
net primary productivity of the trustor
biosphere and so that's a pretty big
carbon footprint and so the UN FAO the
UN Food and Agriculture Organization as
well as several non non governmental
agencies are predicting that somewhere
between 2050 and 2060 we'll need to
increase global crop production by 70 to
120 percent in order to meet
agricultural demand agricultural man
that's being driven by population
increase as well as many of the large
population countries in the world
becoming more affluent and eating
further up the trophic scale and so this
seems like a huge challenge to as much
as double crop production in the next 30
to 40 years you know it's been done
before and so between 1960 and 2005
population on the planet increased 110
percent so it went from about 3 billion
to six-and-a-half billion during that
same 45 years global crop production
increased an incredible 165 percent went
from 1.8 billion tons to 4.8 billion
tons and of course this was called the
Green Revolution one of the important
things to know about that is 135 percent
of that 165 percent increase was due to
intensification due to producing more
per land area and only 25% of that 165
percent was recruiting more land into
agriculture
what this graph shows is that at least
for the land that's under grain
production in the world it Peaks
somewhere in the nineteen middle 1980s
to the 1990s and it's either been
declining slowly or staying or staying
plateaued over that time and so
apparently what that means is that if
we're gonna have to double crop
production then we're gonna have to do
it on approximately the same hundred
twenty million hectares that are under
cultivation today and so that means
really doubling productivity on the land
area basis and that also means then that
this carbon footprint for cultivation
goes from 15 percent to about twenty
five a quarter of all terrestrial carbon
fixation to feed ourselves and to feed
our livestock interested in you too if
you figure in that we're gonna do it on
the same amount of land that suggests
that that primary productivity of the
Tressler biome has to increased by about
twelve percent and so you know I think
this has to qualify as as a grand
challenge that we're going to meet this
projected agricultural demand actually
increase the net primary productivity of
the planet through cultivation of crops
unfortunately it doesn't appear like
things are going in the directions to be
able to meet that demand as as we're
currently practicing agriculture and so
the way to read this figure is that for
the for the 10 year period living ending
in in 1977 so from 1967 to 1977 there
was a decade-old increase of about 30
percent per year in the increase of
yield for these three crops maize rice
and wheat and so these are the three
major crops by production in the world
so about three percent per year that was
sustained through the 80s but by the 90s
you see this dropping and by 2007 which
the last complete dataset you can see
for rice and wheat big drops so far
there hasn't been a been a drop in maize
and and I think another interesting
thing to think about is that China is
the big biggest
producer in the world and also the
biggest race consumer right now they're
investing a thousand times more in race
research than they did in the 70s and
80s and so it suggests us to be able to
stain any kind of increase that
low-hanging fruit might be gone and that
we need to look for different kinds of
trades to optimize in order to create
the situation where we could really
think about increasing crop productivity
on the order of a factor of two and so
what is the cause of that stagnation one
of the cause is almost certainly a
stagnation in yield potential and so
yield potential is the genetic potential
of the crop and so it's defined as
planting a crop in a situation where
that crops well-adapted and is not
limited by the availability of water the
availability of nutrients it's not
assessed beset by pests and pathogens
and it's free from lodging and so it's
the really for a given growing area that
the crops adapted it's the highest yield
you can possibly get new potentials
defined first of all and is constrained
by the amount of the amount of solar
radiation that's available during the
growing season
and so the amount of solar radiation
there that's there to drive distance
this is the total amount of energy
that's available and then there are
three genetically determined things in
the crop that act on that that that then
yield what the yield potential of the
crop is the first is the efficiency of
the crop and intercepting this available
radiation the second is the efficiency
of photosynthesis encouraging converting
this intercepted radiation into biomass
and then the third is the decision that
the crop makes in how much of that
above-ground biomass it's partitioning
or the part of the plant we care about
and so the wheat grain or the maize
grain or the secret
and so what happened in the Green
Revolution in that 165 percent increase
that that happened in the period that I
talked about it was really driven by two
factors here in terms of yield potential
the first is interception efficiency and
so breeders were very good at selecting
for crops that covered the ground very
quickly and so get that first layer out
because any radiation that hits the
ground certainly isn't gonna go across
and the second is that really drove it
in the small grains is this partitioned
efficiency or the harvest index and so
now our best crops for you know soybean
and rice and wheat 60% of all
above-ground dry matter is already
partitioned into into into the grain
itself and so this value now is once a
canopy is formed and across the entire
growing season our best crops are
intercepting about 80 percent of the
total radiation that's available we
think the theoretical upper limit might
be 85 or 90 percent but you know clearly
there isn't the capacity to really
significantly increase the overall yield
potential of our best crops this being
at 60% we think that the upper limit of
that is probably between 65 and 70% you
need pods you need leaves and so not
everything can go go into the sea what
didn't contribute her all to the Green
Revolution was any improvement in this
conversion efficiency the efficiency of
photosynthesis as the question becomes
is there room in terms of increase in
the efficiency of photosynthesis that
would bring us into this realm of being
able to significantly increase yield
potential and so the way to get at that
we think is probably to try to estimate
what the upper efficiency of
photosynthesis is and so we weren't the
first to do this calculation but let's
suppose that we start out with a
thousand villages of sunlight and so
that's all of sunlight the entire solar
spectrum photosynthesis is driven by
essentially a part of the
spectrum that we can see so from 400
nanometers to 700 nanometers which means
about 50% of the quanta they are
available in total sunlight or outside
of the photosynthetically active
spectrum so immediately you have a 50%
reduction in the potential efficiency
plants are green so they're green
because green light doesn't absorb very
well we'll talk a bit more about this
later and is reflected to our eyes and
so there's loss there early in the
season some of its transmitted down to
the ground and so there's a loss there
this photochemical efficiency has to do
with the fact that even though a blue
photon has 1.75 times more energy than
red photon all photosynthesis it's
driven by the energy of a red photon and
so that extra energy in in the blue band
is completely lost to the heat in the
seconds and so isn't available
photosynthesis carbohydrate biosynthesis
is xtronic there's this process of photo
respiration and c3 plants and then
finally there is autotrophic respiration
this respiration we talked about plants
growing themselves and so when you get
through to this it says that the upper
potential for for photosynthetic
efficiency in a c3 plant like a soybean
plant or a wheat plant is about 5% c4
plants are a bit higher so plants like
maize and sugarcane can do about six and
a half to seven percent the maximum
that's ever been observed across an
entire growing season is about half of
that and so this comes from these farmer
competition trials where where they grow
these small plots and competition for
the highest yield and the average that's
observed force a high input farmers in
the Midwest was about 1% and so we
suggest this difference between 2.5 and
5 or this 1.5 and 2.5 is an opportunity
to significantly increase yield
and so why is photosynthesis so
inefficient you know so why is it
operating at 1% or two and a half
percent rather than the theoretical
fibers there's a number of reasons but
the one I want to talk to about today is
this one and that is this is the
dependence of photosynthesis of carbon
gained in the plant on the intensity of
light that's available and so this is in
micro moles per meter squared per second
and so you know in champaign-urbana
during the growing season the maximum
light intensity is about 2000 micro
Reinstein is per meter like it and if it
gets probably down here someone but but
what this shows is that photosynthesis
in a soybean plant or a wheat plant
saturates at about twenty to twenty-five
percent of full sunlight on a sunny day
at the top of the soybean canopy it's
spending 75% of its time absorbing all
this light and not increase in
photosynthesis so it's wasted and the
paradox is that one leaf layer down
those needs are limited and so the
hypothesis of our plants to green comes
from this notion that these top layers
of leaves absorbing way more light than
they can use but one leaf layer down
those leaves are light starved
we could let more of that light in
deeper into the canopy they it could be
used with higher efficiency and
therefore we would expect more canopy
photosynthesis that would could drive a
higher yield potential and so this is
the notion so here's our soybean plant a
full green soybean leaf has an
absorptance for photosynthetically
active light of about pointing on my no
DS so it it absorbs ninety percent of
light visible so one leaf layer down
it's ten percent of the incident light
to leaf layers now it's 50% of the
insulate and so if we look here then on
our lay response curve or photosynthesis
here we're way over saturated one leaf
layer down we're all down
least limited to meet layers down we're
down here very close to like
compensation and so the very simple
notion that drove the beginning of this
program was if we just do a simple
calculation on beers law if we reduce
the chlorophyll concentration seventy
percent we still saturate photosynthesis
here and now the second leaf layer down
is close to saturation and even the
third leaf layer down is is contributing
net photosynthesis the spoiler is it's
not this simple and so this is lipolysis
increasing light transmittance through
the leaf will increase canopy leaf
litter and so the way we wanted to start
this out was to do a more sophisticated
model and see what the model really
predicts and so we modeled this for a
leaf area index of four and so that
means having a canopy in which the the
area of the leaves is four times the
area of the ground that it covers and so
soybean gets up to a leaf layer index of
seven eight nine
you know we six eight nine something
like that and so and so and so this is
modeled then for an entire day with this
kind of profile and it's modeled for a
particular day a year and it's modeled
for 40 degrees north latitude which
affects this the amount of solar energy
that's available and 40 degrees north
latitude is essentially the latitude of
the middle of the Corn Belt and and so
when light comes in it has three
potential fades it could be absorbed
shown here it could be reflected or it
could be transmitted and so of course
what we're after is trying to increase
the amount that's being transmitted to
lower levels and so if we calculate then
for a full green leaf what the
contribution is of each lead to to
photosynthesis across the day we get
this kind of profile leaf one notice the
change in scale now leaf too early in
the day it's actually negative to
respiration and then leaf three there's
almost no net it's in fact it's all
negative
and in lis flair for it's all negative
and so then we can calculate what the
the net amount of co2 that is fixed per
land area and this is what's really
important when you're thinking about
tent intensification and in our model
then we can ask so here's the pool green
leaf that's absorbing 80 percent eighty
six percent of the incoming radiation
and what the model suggests is that if
we reduce that to fifty five percent by
lowering the chlorophyll concentration
we should get about a 30 percent
increase in the daily integral
photosynthesis on a land area basis for
canopy that has a leaf area index of
poor okay and so this is just looking at
light absorption by the soybean canopy
that that we measured in urbana and so
what you can see is that and so day one
90 is shortly after emergence then by
day 197 we have a least berry index of
about 2.7 and you can see that there is
that the amount of light that's being
absorbed is is plateaued absorbing about
95 percent of the total radiation and so
there's little question that breeders
have been able to optimize the canopy
from the standpoint of total light
interception but our question is hasn't
optimized where that lights being
absorbed in the canopy and our policy is
that it that it hasn't and so we said
about when we started this project to
look at a light green mutant of soybean
and there was two advantage of this one
it existed and we didn't have to
engineer it and the second was that we
were able to look at a plant that was
isogenic for there was isogenic either
than this one mutation that existed in
the chlorophyll biosynthetic pathway we
were able to show that the mutation here
is in the enzyme of magnesium killer
taste which is an enzyme in the BIOS
badly clearly it's not knock down its
activity is just not M and so what we
wanted to do here was to use a technique
of light sheet microscopy to look at the
penetration of light into a full green
leaf versus the penetration of light
into one of these light green leaves and
these light green leaves had a total
chlorophyll content was 65 percent lower
than the wild-type and so they look like
houseplants so they're they're really
quite light green and so what we do with
this technique is from the top of the
leaf or the bottom of the leaf but but
the top belief we illuminate the leaf
with different colors of laser light and
then from the edge of the leaf we detect
chlorophyll fluorescence and so
chlorophyll fluorescence the intensity
of the chlorophyll fluorescence is
proportional to the amount of light that
reaches that depth in the leaf and we
can do this for different colors of
light and so and so illuminating from
the top of the light if these are false
colored of course but if we luminate
with blue light you can see that almost
all of the light is absorbed at the very
top of the canopy red light penetrates a
little bit further and green light we
know what that is reflected and so it's
not it's not absorbed very well at all
penetrates quite deep in the leaf if we
compare that to the light green leaf
that has 65% less chlorophyll blue legs
penetrating a bit more deeply red lights
penetrating a lot more deeply and it
doesn't affect green light very much and
so we can understand this pretty well
and so the two major chlorophyll
pigments in higher plants or chlorophyll
a and chlorophyll B and so they absorb
strongly in the red it's strong very
strongly in the blue and they absorbed
very weakly in the green and so we
expect green light because it's not
being absorbed strongly we expect it to
be transmitted more and we expect it to
be reflected more blue light which is
absorbed most strongly we expect it to
be absorbed very strongly and because
it's being absorbed strongly the amount
of transmittance and the amount of
lectins is going to be low and red light
is the intermediate
and so if we quantitate that so we can
quantitate those figures and what you
can see is what we saw qualitatively
that blue light is penetrating more
deeply in these light green leaves red
light even more deeply and green light
not very much
these figures over here are illuminating
from the bottom of leaf which we did
because we could and so then if we look
at photosynthesis based on gas exchange
as a function of the light intensity we
do see an improvement in efficiency of
photosynthesis but notice that this is a
PR and so this is absorbed
photosynthetically active radiation so
it's not incident what I showed you
previously was incident and so this is
what's being absorbed and so what's
happening at least our interpretation is
that now there's less over saturation in
the chloroplasts at the top of the leaf
with blue light and red light they're
penetrating deeper into the leaf -
chloroplasts that aren't saturated and
therefore that light can be used
somewhat more efficiently green light it
doesn't matter so much in a single leaf
because it's already penetrating quite
well but also being reflected and so I
told you at the beginning it's more
complicated than this and so the
complication really becomes in this
issue of reflectance and so the
difference between and so and so the
reason you get a lot of reflectance in
the leaf is that there's a lot of air
spaces in the leaf and so when light
comes in and it goes through a cell it's
going through an aqueous environment
that has a different refractive index
than air and so every time it goes into
an aqueous space comes out into an air
space and the leaf refractive index
changes and there's light scatter and
it's doing this several times and that
scattered light depending upon
redirection try to be reflected light or
it could be transmitted light
when you think about it in our model of
a leaf area index poor anything that you
reflect from the top of the canopy
doesn't have a chance to get reabsorbed
by the leaves above it and so it just
goes back into space and it's lost to
the canopy as total solar radiation
that's available to driveways and so
that suggests that there should be a
sweet spot there should be a sweet spot
of lowering chlorophyll to the point
where you can increase transmittance but
not so much that you have lost total
radiation that you're actually lowering
photosynthesis based on less light
available to be absorbed and so in our
model we can do a sensitivity analysis
of you know what are the most important
things in determining you know what what
yield potential is going to be and one
of the things you find out is it's you
know it's really this issue of the
relationship of how changes in
absorptivity afleck reflect reflectivity
and transmissivity and so originally in
the model we were using this equation
for dense canopies and it's kind of an
empirical fudged equation and when we
discovered how sensitive the model was
to to this issue of reflectance we
figured that we really needed to find
out for soybean you know what is the
relationship between optical properties
leaf a pneumatic lure filled agenda
leash and so at the University of
Illinois we have the USDA germ plasm
collection for soybean and in that
collection our 68 different light green
is a lot of them are light green mutants
for really bad reasons and they're
really sick plants but nevertheless we
have chlorophyll concentrations that go
from 50 micro moles per meter squared up
to full grain of 500 micro moles per
meter squared that so happens across
those 68 they're pretty well spread out
in chlorophyll concentration and so we
can go in then and we grew them all out
in the field and then we measure the
optical properties every one of those
leaves to get the relationship between
chlorophyll content in a soybean leaf
and how that partition into reflectance
how that partition into transmittance
and then we also measure a lot of
photosynthetic properties from those
leaves and then we use that information
in order to parameterize the models
we're using actual measured values as a
function of chlorophyll concentration
rather than assumed and what it shows
qualitatively is what you expect and
that is the leaf transmittance and leaf
reflectance increase with decrease in
absorbance and so here we see this
relationship for leaf reflectance versus
chlorophyll and so chlorophyll
concentrations going down in this
direction and this is wavelength and so
what you can see is that as chlorophyll
concentration is going up reflectance is
going down and vice versa in the red and
here you can see the green window and
then blue here is absorbed so strongly
in the in both the full green leaves and
the light green leaf that there's really
very little reflectance predicted in the
model
here's leaf transmittance and so this is
what we're trying to maximize and then
here's total leaf absorbance and so what
the model predicts is that chlorophyll
can be reduced up to 60% with very
little seasonal penalty to crop
photosynthesis and so this looks at
total light absorbed and and total daily
integral of photosynthesis as a function
of day of year and so this is as the
crops developing and that's over what it
is in the depth of the canopy so anytime
you see red it means that the light
green leaf is performing better in the
areas you see blue it means that the
dark green life is growing there and so
this is then integrated here and here's
the full green leaf and here's the light
green leaf and so it says that there is
some penalty in terms of the total light
that's absorbed over the growing season
and any time during the
season and that penalty then in the
model shows up as a penalty to to net
photosynthesis and so it's interesting
to know you know and so this model
suggests that plants yes very much over
invested in chlorophyll but it doesn't
support our hypothesis that in fact we
should see an increase in canopy
photosynthesis and so the model is not
predicting that and so this is modeled
for this for the full green and and this
mutant soybean y11 and so when we made
those measurements in the field we made
them over two years in in year one of
that experiment if you look down here at
CEO a gram per meter squared there's
about a 10% penalty in yield and that's
you know and so that's pretty in there
pretty much violet validates what you
know what the model suggests in the
second year this was 2012 and we had a
huge drought and so we saw bigger yield
penalties in in y11 in year two y11 does
have a playa tropic effect and so even
though the mutation is in they need some
tequila taste which is a four subunit
enzyme that's involved in the
biosynthesis of coral it turns out that
one of those subunits which is in the
envelope of the chloroplast membrane is
involved in ABA signaling and this why I
let a mutant isn't able to control its
domains and so they stay open during
drought and and they their water use
efficiency goes down and so we're
suspicious during this drought here that
that's the reason and so what we really
wanted to know is if the model could
tell us why you know why aren't you know
what is it that limits light green from
not being a more productive canopy with
just a canopy in which we can get rid of
a lot of chlorophyll getting rid a lot
of chlorophyll in another cell makes a
good sense because if we assume that all
of that chlorophyll a and chlorophyll b
are associated with the harvested
pigment proteins of photosystem 1 and
photosystem 2 and they
most certainly are then we expect a nine
percent nitrogen savings for a 40 for a
60% decrease in the chlorophyll
concentration of the leaf and so what
the model told us was well a big issue
here is the loss of photosynthetic
complete radioactive photosynthetically
active radiation from the canopy did
reflectance and then there's and related
to that is this early season penalty and
so it's a time when when there there is
a real disadvantage of being like green
early indices and so two reasons for
that one is the canopies small and any
reflected light has a lower probability
of being really greener being
intercepted and then secondly it doesn't
do any good to transmit more light
through the canopy that's going to hit
the ground and then the third is that in
spite of the fact that there is a
nitrogen savings it turns out that
soybean aren't real bright and so they
don't take advantage of this extra
nitrogen savings and reinvest that into
photosynthetic apparatus in areas of the
canopy where the light intensity is now
higher and so we have been successful
and I'm not showing the bedroom we have
been successful of increasing light
intensity lower in the canopy but the
plants aren't redeploying the
photosynthetic apparatus and so what can
we do about that and so this just shows
this so I've showed you this before for
the full green canopy and now you can
see for this light green canopy that
there is the significant penalty early
in the season even though the leaf area
index in the light green is actually a
little bit higher than the leaf area
index in the dark so there's much leaf
area there but there's high reflectance
here and some of the transmittance is
being lost to the ground and so we
wanted to be able to get around this
early season penalty one of the ways to
potentially get around this early season
penalty is not to turn on the light
green trait until you have canopy
closure
and so what we wanted then was to to put
a an inhibition in chlorophyll synthesis
behind an inducible promoter so that we
could turn on the light green trait
deeper into the season and so the way
that we started out to do that is to use
an ethanol inducible promoter yes we're
on the field spraying soybean plants
actually this is being done in tobacco
and so again we're expressing a small
RNA and that small RNA is targeted to
magnesium killers and this experiment is
currently underway and and so this is a
field experiment that's ongoing
obviously this is a drone photo of it
and we have in each one of these blocks
we have three wild-type
and then we have three each of two to
transform its with this ethanol and
dishonor both of these transformers work
well in our greenhouse and chamber
studies but only one of the transformers
responded to the ethanol spraying in the
field and we think it has to do with
temperature because we did do some
greenhouse experiments where the
temperature was high and this this one
transformed didn't respond and so we
spray with ethanol every morning at dawn
and you can see after five days of
spraying we're now seeing in in one of
these transform ins a consistent
decrease in the amount of chlorophyll
that's there and so we're getting about
a forty to fifty five percent reduction
in chlorophyll following the ethanol
spray in the transgenic plants here is
this effect of the absorbance the
transmittance and their reflections and
so remember I told you that what the
model predicts is we wanted to go from
the wild green type of eighty six
percent interest interception of the
light down to 55 percent and so if we
compare this a fifty five percent
in the amount of chlorophyll translates
into a decrease in absorbance down to
about 60% of the income incoming light
and so we're very close to what the
model predicts as being ideal and this
experiment is still ongoing and so we
know and so we do have green leaves at
the bottom canopy we are getting higher
levels of light in the canopy you know
whether this will translate into a
canopy that has a higher biomass we
don't know right now and so we're doing
this experiment now and we're planting a
replicate experiment and in Puerto Rico
next week and so we'll get 2 replicates
of that this year and so this is one of
the ways that we're after to deal both
with this issue of reflectance early in
the season and this issue of lost
absorbance early in the season loss
absorbency both due to reflectance as
well as transmittance through to through
to the ground so the second thing we're
thinking about of increasing the
transparency of lead because that's what
we want to do we want to increase the
amount of light that gets through it is
there a way to increase the transparency
without invoking as much loss due to
reflectance and so another potential way
to go about increasing the transmittance
of light is to take advantage of the
Civic light and and so on teaching
photosynthesis right now and the way I
explain the simple fact in class is that
if you have an ink bottle of ink and you
set it in the bathtub floor water
you've changed absorbance that bathtub
very very little if you take that same
amount of ink and you divide it into a
thousand eight bottles you've changed
the absorbance more and if you pour it
in then you increase the absorbance most
and so that is that is a qualitative
example of the civil right
thus in effect is actually more
complicated or more intricate and that
is that it has to do with the wavelength
of light and the wavelength the lights
that the chlorophyll or the chromophore
is absorbing and so in this example if
we take this to be a cube at full of
chlorophyll and we're illuminating with
monochromatic red light I've told you
that a fully green leaf absorbs about
90% of that light which means and and
and so if you do that in the red and
remember I said you know chlorophyll a
and chlorophyll b absorbs strongly in
the red as well as in the blue sarey if
you do it in the green then about eighty
percent of the light is transmitted and
thus orbits about twenty percent then
the SIV effect means take all of this
chromophore take all of this chlorophyll
and put it in just happening to you that
and the other half of the to bat just
has solvent same thing down here and now
we have now we have the transmittance
here that's point five but a
transmittance here that fifty percent
and so now we're luma nating this whole
cube that with monochromatic light and
so this solvent is absorbing any of the
red light and this is absorbing more of
the red light based on beers law and now
absorbance of red light for chlorophyll
has gone from 90% but for green light
the effect on total absorbance is very
small
the reason being it wasn't strongly
absorbed in the first place and so again
we're not interfering with the
transmission of green light into the
canopy and incidentally if you didn't
know green light drives approximately 50
percent fifty fifty-five percent of all
the photosynthesis in a dense canopy
simply because it is transmitted in the
canopy where it confused more
efficiently once you get to a leaf area
index a poor none of its reaching the
ground and so the notion that green
light is inefficient in driving go to
senses you know may be true on a
chloroplast basis
certainly not true and so we wanted to
try to take advantage of this sip effect
and so the way to do this in the
chloroplast you go back to the the ink
bottle example is to make it fewer ink
bugs right and so you know rather than
having a thousand bottles you know let's
see if we can get down to 200 or 28 Kos
in the way we went about doing that is
to interfere with chloroplast addition
and so this has been worked out very
well in a rabid opposites by Kathy
Ulster Hall deficient state and there's
a number of proteins that are involved
in chloroplast division and one of them
is is at C and so we made an RNA I -
fitzy in order to lower its expression
therefore as she showed in an
Arabidopsis you can pretty much titrate
the size of the chloroplast based on the
amount of fitzy that you allow deform
and and it appears that what happens is
that total chloroplast volume doesn't
change total chlorophyll doesn't change
but the number of packets that you
deploy didn't get smaller and smaller
gets fewer and fewer as the core clan
chloroplasts get bigger and bigger and
so this is shown and I apologize to you
or changing organisms but this work was
supported by DOA and so we were working
on sorghum and sugarcane in this case
and so Freddie al Peter took our
construct and transformed it into
sugarcane and so sugarcane is one of
these seed or plants that has two kinds
of chloroplasts and here's the normal
size in chloroplasts and it has this
volume and we have lots of different
transformants and some of these
transforms have chlorophyll
concentration or plastic dimes that are
five and six times larger and so this
this should you know based on modeling
have a significant effect on sit effect
and increase the transparency the leaf
and based on modeling you should have
lower reflectance
and so this is the parental line so this
is I'm switching again this this is
actually sorghum in this case and so
this is the parental line of sorghum
doing light sheet microscopy as we've
done before you can see the penetration
of light into the leaf based on these
different with these different
wavelengths and so these are the ways
laid with laser wavelengths have changed
and so when we increase the volume by a
factor of five you can see that we are
increasing the transmission of the or
the penetration of these like deeper
into the canopy and so these not these
plants but the sugarcane plants were
planted out in an experiment that was
done in at Florida State by pretty al
peter and we saw about a 10% increase in
the biomass of these plants when they're
planted out and no change in the amount
of sucrose accumulated it's a little bit
problematic because actually that
increase of biomass is larger than
particular our models based on the
amount of transmission so we're still
trying to so just summarize but I told
you today is that field experiments with
soybean and with tobacco have validated
our canopy model that there's almost no
penalty in light absorption of carbon
gained with a 60% reduction in
chlorophyll and that 60 percent
reduction in chlorophyll is equivalent
to a 9 percent savings in nitrogen it's
interesting in all of these plants that
we've measured where we've reduced
chlorophyll even though we've been able
to show that they're not investing in
chlorophyll they're not investing in
those chlorophyll proteins those are
gone the C to n ratio hasn't changed and
so they're partitioning this this extra
nitrogen into vegetative storage
proteins at least in the case of soybean
and tobacco and so the nitrogen is still
there these are growing under very
nitrogen
conditions but they're not reinvesting
that nitrogen in ways that would help
the plant and then the canopy identified
three major limitations that prevent the
light green trait from actually
improving canopy photosynthesis and
pruning yield as I said they were lost
due to reflectance this penalty of light
green and that the light green plants
don't reinvest their nitrogen in
increasing photosynthetic capacity in
those areas of the canopy where the
light intensity is going on and so what
are the next steps and so I told you one
of them and that is to use light
inducible promoters to try to sustain
the full green phenotype until canopy is
closed and then induced low green
phenotype obviously our plan is not to
do this long-term with ethanol sprays
postdoc doing is pretty tired of getting
up at you know at dawn to spray and so
we either want to use a phytochrome
promoter or there's a group that we're
collaborating with Germany who believe
they have a motor that actually responds
to light intensity and so either of
these potentially could work to get the
phenotype that we want which is light
cream top of the canopy dark green at
the bottom of canopy the other thing we
want to do is that our models suggest
that combining low chlorophyll with a
large and chloroplast trait should be
the best of both worlds in terms of
increasing transmittance and minimizing
the increase of reflectance and then
finally it's this issue of nitrogen
nitrate now I just mentioned that all of
these experiments have been done under
nitrogen replete conditions so in the
case of the back of tobacco loves
nitrogen so it's actually grown at twice
the amount of nitrogen that we put on
these and so maybe it's the case that
under these luxurious nitrogen
conditions the the plant doesn't have to
make a choice and therefore is you know
just keeps it same nitrogen as I said oh
well maybe I haven't said but much of
this work is supported by the Gates
Foundation and their interest is really
in not high input agriculture but their
interest is in the agricultural
sustainable farmers
that are growing in these very bad
tropical soils and they don't have
access to fertilizer and so our
hypothesis that we want to test is that
under conditions when nitrogen is very
limiting that that plants may take
advantage of this nitrogen savings and
reinvest it in a way that actually takes
advantage of this change that isn't that
they're going to do better than the high
nitrogen situation but compared to a
full green low nitrogen plant the
hypothesis that they will do and so the
the model is assuming partitioning
efficiency and so that's not a variable
in the model we could put it as a
variable model if you could
experimentally parameters what that
would be and so what we've the only the
only field experiments that we've done
with light green that I'm confident in
the harvest index is with the y11 light
green soybean and in that case we do not
see a statistically significant change
in harvest index you know whether that's
going to be true over a wide range of of
light green plants and particularly when
we make that cross from leguminous
plants turn on like you this plants we
don't know you show this slide and gave
us the perspective of the horizontal
incoming radiation and then you did what
the effect would be of having angle
leaves a vertical position which would
be another way of getting exposing that
leaf to a lower flex density that's not
standing and absolutely you're
completely right and so another another
way to get Ad creating better homogenic
originating and light penetration in the
canopy is to change leave angle and so
there there is work going on in our
gates funded project to look at both
natural variation in leaf angle as well
as engine engineered variation so in
maize a number of the genes that are
involved in leave angle are known and so
in fact that's not in the right projects
it's an it's not a daily project for the
C pores and so both natural variation in
that is being looked at as well as and
then you know the plan is then as to you
know if we can work out this light green
trade is to try to partner the two even
in soybean there is a lot of genetic
variation and leaf angle and leaf shape
and Lisa Ainsworth is doing a natural
variation looking across a big diversity
panel in soybean to look at that and you
know and what she finds early in the
season that it does matter and once you
get there big leaf area index it doesn't
matter yeah and so a lot of that has
been bred out in most modern cultivars
but yeah and some of the historical
Devore's
it's really a problem and it becomes a
real problem to model too because in
order to parameterize the model you
change the night surfing organization
and enzymes like is playing with those
like a steak reading phenotype green you
don't have our grand closing content
like fix that yeah and so the question
is what about a stay green phenotype so
a phenotype that stays green longer and
in season and increases essentially the
growing season period of Cetaphil
depending upon you know what crop it is
and if it's the kind of stay green in
which the plant stays green and stays
photosynthetically active in fact that
has been shown to increase yield and the
reason it increases you know that
increases s you know in that equation
increases the total amount of solar
energy that's collected during this
collected during the season and and so
you know have we thought about combining
that we have and many and the genes are
known
and so the question is about is there a
change in photo an inhibition or photo
damage and so our hypothesis was
actually that the amount of photo damage
would go down because the amount of
total light that's being absorbed and so
one of the main ways in which plans deal
with all this excess light that I showed
you that they get very much of the day
is is through a process that's been
unfortunately dubbed non photochemical
quenching and so it's a process by which
excited chlorophyll can be be excited
through some carotenoids and releases
and it's quite easy to measure because
you can measure so we expected the
amount of this non photochemical
quenching to go down and it didn't
change so again this is something that
is contrary to what we think the plant
but that's also Engineering and so you
know engineer the amount of non
photochemical quenching that's done
because the genes that are involved in
doing that are known and it's already
been shown in model systems and there's
also natural occurring genetic creation'
you know it may there's been to be years
with the selection where if there any
light elite
days greater than it was 50 years ago
and I would say no if anything I would
say it's the other direction that things
have gotten greener and so if you'd
asked me this year ago I would have put
the blame on you breeders and saying
that you guys don't like look like green
and so you rip them out you know and
then and then the second thing is
depending how big your plot is you know
he could be shaded by full green what I
would say now is that our modeling
predicts that it should and so and so I
don't so what I think is that is that is
that I would predict that you would see
a very small penalty for being light
green in those trials but not something
that you would pick out and so if it is
going to be successful it's going to
have to be something that that stacks a
couple of different traits to try to
circumvent these things that we I mean I
guess reflect in questions my impression
is that Mays Lee bangle has done closer
but at the same time crowding tolerance
has gotten better and so maize breeders
have taken advantage of that and light
penetration
like all these strategies their
selection of a favor and the kind of
wondering which one is which and the
generation of making the bread line you
probably would win be planning it baby
fur and yourself and we haven't and so
you know as I said we're planning to do
that in the tobacco experiment but maybe
we should do it in the mutants that we
know much more about but the mutants and
we know a lot about our leg and we
actually could do a lot of that our
canopy model
and so the canopy model is driven you
know by meteorology that we measure but
it's also driven by parameterization
before we put in in terms of you know
nitrogen supply as well as all the
measured parameters ation surfaces and
so we could put that in and take some
tweaking the model but that's a good
suggestion sort of general way to work
in the opposite direction at least with
some crop plants and increase and
decrease the number of leaves get a gain
and so and so if we run this same canopy
model
which we can do and ask the question
when parameterised or a full green
soybean you know under the growing you
know prioritizing with all the
meteorological data from a growing
season in Illinois it turns out that the
ideal be very index from for a soybean
plant is four point one and so it often
goes to eight and so you're you're right
the model suggests that it very much
over invests in the amount of leaves
that it's producing and and you know why
you think that that might have to do
with respiratory load the model suggests
that the real reason is investment in
making that leaf when you when you first
grow it and so and so Steve Wong's group
did an experiment where they went out
and they clipped every third trifoliate
from soybean plants before it was lad to
expand then again soybean plants are not
very cooperative and so as soon as they
did that they they branched born so they
weren't getting the depression the leaf
area index if they wanted but they got
it from eight down to six and when they
got it from eight down to six there was
a significant increase in field
experiments on field trials about and so
you know that's that's not defining you
know and again I don't think farmers
you're going to send out twenty five
undergraduates to clip their so you you
know but maybe there are some genetic
controls and so absolutely at the
planning densities that we were using I
think most crops are over investing in
in leaves after canopy closure
Norrish how you achieve the same goal by
his careful management Delta nitrogen I
say you develop a nitrogen management
regime that allows their method cannot
be Area Development burning this evening
and then Lancet the canopies we develop
to you lower the nitrogen so that it
leaves will become white grain yeah well
I suppose you could but I would guess
that there would be a yield penalty
associated with the nitrogen that's
available to put in succeed during
senior I would thinking something like
rice or wheat that would be disastrous
well soybean it's a difficult experiment
because normally in in Illinois where we
grow soybean and maize
there's enough carryover of nitrogen
from the previous soy crop that they
don't know late and begin to fix
nitrogen into late July and you know and
so I think if you did that experiment in
in soybean they just nod you late way
earlier there are non modulating sleep
thank you very much this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu